so this is a false statement so we got
to call it out should prophet mohammed
who was a slave trader should mosques be
torn down any garbage that's coming out
of your mouth
assalamu alaikum greetings of peace now
what brought us to be covering this
topic
was this i can't stand the veil you know
and then you have here in the west you
know
mattel coming out with the veiled barbie
and
nike coming out with nike coming out
with them
hijab with a swoosh and and then there
was actually more someone sent me
another
clip of what seemed like some malicious
jabs
there are some low blows should prophet
muhammed who was a slave trader
attacking the one who's beloved to close
to two billion human beings
living today prophet muhammed peace and
blessings be upon him
attacking him insulting him by our
friend patrick
ben david should prophet muhammed who
was a slave trader should mosques be
torn down
are you listening to this yeah
yeah i just wanted to make sure that my
girlfriend is listening to this
garbage garbage that's coming out of
your mouth now there's a couple options
here
either a our friend is just extremely
ignorant when it comes to this topic or
b
the person has a malicious is very
disingenuous and has a malicious agenda
thus you see some of the low blows the
insults the attacks that are coming in
this way
that this is a real problem this
ideology
is a real problem some politicians
saying that you know islam is a religion
of peace
perpetrating that narrative by the way
when you said the the
muslim is a religion of peace that
politician you mentioned is a president
he's a two-term president that you were
mentioning i believe you were
there are two presidents there's george
bush who said that
there's barack obama who said that
and the whole press
the mainstream media all of the
mainstream media
perpetrated that narrative um
for the past you know 20 years
what's what's interesting do you follow
bill maher do you follow bill maher at
all or no
yes the one thing impressive about bill
maher is when he came down to even
though he's a very very
uh uh far left uh uh uh democrat himself
he he was not on in the same camp as the
rest of them when it came down to the
topic of islam but
let's go with option number one that our
friend is just
extremely ignorant and look this is
said with no disrespect now there's a
quote by a wise man who said
it's easier to fool people and harder to
convince people that they've been fooled
now that can be synonymous
with they've been tricked they've been
duped
they've become victims of the hate
propaganda the hate machine
which is a business for many bashing
islam
writing books negative books about islam
propaganda against islam and muslims and
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him
i mean this has been going on since the
beginning so this is nothing new
so many people have become victims to
this hate machine but again
there's a famous quote leaders are
readers so our friend patrick ben david
likes to read so we'll give him some
homework at the end
and inshallah god willing he can grow
from this experience
and i'm sharing this really out of the
love love for humanity
love for the people and this is also a
person who tries to spread that he tries
to educate people
and he also shares many of the views
that we share
because he caters to more of a
conservative
audience and that's just amazing we're
actually more conservative than the
conservative
and more christian we'd say than the
christian and all you got to do is watch
some of the deen's show and get to know
islam
to see that this fact this is fact not
fiction now with the first part with
this
guest that he had you know attacking
hijab attacking islam
i can't stand the veil you know and then
you have here in the west you know
mattel coming out with the veiled barbie
and
nike coming out with nike coming out
with them
hijab with a swoosh and i'll cover that
towards the end
but this part where he calls he has a
direct attack on prophet muhammed
insulting him attacking him saying that
he was a prophet mohammed who was a
slave trader
this is not something that is
academically sound
this is not something that any historian
somebody who studies the life of prophet
muhammed academically
sincerely looks at it would walk away
with it so this is a false statement so
we got to call it out
and i'm just going to touch upon this
and then i'm going to share with him
and the audience what some non-muslims
had to say about prophet muhammad those
who really looked at his life genuinely
sincerely so to make this statement
this false statement this attack not
only is it insulting
to 2 billion human beings in the world
this is insulting to the creator of the
heavens and earth the one who sent the
prophet muhammad
not as a slave trader no but he came his
title was
as a mercy to all of mankind and to you
my friend patrick people know muslims
know and they share this that look
islam which means look let's qualify the
term what does islam mean islam means to
acquire peace by
submitting your will to the creator of
the heavens and earth the same god that
jesus submitted to moses abraham and the
last the final message of muhammad peace
and blessings be upon
them all so we know and now you'll know
also that islam came to free the necks
of the slave
let's put it in context what happened
before the last and final messenger
was sent on the scene even during jesus
time and in between
was slavery a norm yes it was a social
norm it was something that
islam didn't invent this is what human
beings invented this is what human
beings spread on the earth the
oppression of human beings upon other
human beings so this is something that
was prevalent
during and before the time of prophet
muhammad so you had people taking free
human beings kidnapping them
taking them making them into slaves
something abhorrent something despicable
the greatest oppression can you imagine
someone who was born free kidnapped
tortured
and made into slaves kind of reminds you
of the
atlantic trade slave that happened here
in america where actually in actuality
you had 30 to 40 percent of those
people who were free human beings who
are made into slaves
they were actually muslims so they were
actually muslims who helped actually
build this country
this is this man up there yes yourself
if you study a little bit of the history
if you read more of these type of books
not just books on money money money how
to make money
i mean and it just becomes all about
that but if you study this type of this
history that's out there
you you'll get to know that in fact
you'll be surprised to find out that
many of your ancestors when they came
from
europe in different places muslims were
already here to greet your ancestors
that's true in fact muslims were
celebrating
ramadan and muslim
our holidays friends were celebrating
christmas with the christmas tree
now back to the to the to the matter at
hand so islam came to deal with the root
of the matter the racism that was at the
hearts of the people
so islam came to open the doors and
close the door open the doors of freeing
the next of the slaves look look this is
ayah this
verse from the quran where god almighty
is saying and what will help you
on the steep path it is the freeing of
someone's neck this is the freeing of
the slav of the slaves look at that
so slavery was something that was of the
norm and then here comes prophet
muhammad peace and blessings upon him
encouraging because this is divinely
sent to freeze to start it became one of
the greatest acts of worship
so when you put things in context you
see that there was wars there was
winners and losers of these wars and
what are you going to do with the people
the losers of these wars what are you
going to do with them what are you going
to do islam had a solution for all of
that
islam and the teachings of prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
and his strong actions
which advocated the freeing of the
slaves integrating them into the society
making them more powerful educating them
they became governors
they became leaders of communities i
mean this is like unheard of
and islam did all this it became again
one of the greatest acts of worship
to free a slave closing those doors of
making people slaves because there's an
authentic statement by the last and
final messenger center mechanic prophet
muhammad is quoting god almighty the
creator in arabic allah where he says
there are three people who will be
enemies of mine on the day of judgment
god almighty is saying and one of those
is the one who takes a free man get this
a man who sold a free man and consumed
his price
look so it closed the door that's one of
the avenues no no islam closed that door
right so it's a natural progression to
go ahead and eradicate it all together
and then if a person did have because
you have to qualify the term also
what we can what the term you hear today
is slavery
rights a slave if you took that back
then some of it would qualify as an
indentured servant
also you also had this going on at that
time you had people
who now who were better off in a
situation
where they can live with someone and
they can offer their services
and now they were indebted they were
indentured servants so you also had this
class of people and one of the avenues
of closing the door where it became so
if you did have someone
that was under your care in this avenue
you couldn't call this is my slave
because
we truly the only real slave the slave
of the creator the slave of god
this is truly only who we should be
slaves to
right and islam came to free the human
being from being
a slave to creation but to be a slave to
the creator that heavens and earth so if
someone at that time did have a slave
you had to clothe him the same can you
imagine that
you had to feed him the same right he
would pray with you and you would pray
i mean it became it just wasn't good for
business right and then if you did a sin
right you have to expedia him let alone
hitting a slave
let alone beating a slave this was
unheard of look a
a person who ended up hitting a slave
beating their sl they'd end up end up
having to free them i mean you couldn't
do that it was it was a rule that you
could not do
and this was all part of the teachings
of islam next point if
prophet muhammad was a slave trader
prophet mohammed who was a slave trader
and then he was promoting this
then his companions his family members
they would end up just compiling and
compiling and compiling more and more
and more in slaves and it would just
continue on but no
it was just a slow eradication process
again closing the doors of it
and opening the opening doors of freeing
freeing the slave there's a famous story
below
he found him and he was being tortured
why because he was saying
god is one god is one like the pure
monotheism
and then what happened companion prophet
muhammad because of the teachings of
islam because of that what
we said the freeing of the slave he
bought him and freed him look
this is just one example and based on
that in the teachings of prophet
muhammad
what happened thousands upon thousands
his family members
and companions and those who wanted to
get near the cigar
they ended up freeing thousands of
thousands of thousands of thousands of
slaves
and these slaves end up becoming
governors becoming leaders they become
they became prestigious individuals
scholars this is on
this was unheard of now just to contrast
that with the bible and christianity and
again this is not disparaging our
christian friends
or patrick because he's a he's a
christian he always you see him wearing
the cross
so this is not the disparities but just
you make a contrast you see that islam
came to weaken the slavery
to weaken slavery to go ahead and free
the next slave but
the bible actually in christianity
confirmed it it didn't come to eradicate
it i mean this is a fact i mean this is
something that
what you could actually because you
bring on guests you bring on guests to
debate communism
and capitalism this is if you're sincere
you want to know if you're like
look if i want to know a topic and now
i'm a talk show host i'm going to bring
someone on we could say we could talk
about this right
in a nice benign peaceful manner let's
get to the truth and let's help educate
ourselves and educate the people on this
but don't like throw like jabs and you
know
low blows should prophet mohammed who
was a slave trader should mosques be
torn down
that's not right that's not befitting
you patrick so if we look at
christianity just to make a contrast it
confirmed slavery as it had been
affirmed beforehand by judaism
there was no text in any of the gospels
that prohibited or denounced
slavery at all so it's really
astonishing when you see
certain neophytes in this area who get
out of their lane
because if someone's sincere and genuine
because there are a lot of christians
who are sincere genuine and other
non-muslims who are out there and we'll
get to those
in a minute towards the end but others
who just have this malicious agenda and
i'm not putting that label on
on our friend here patrick i'm i'm
thinking that okay i'm giving him the
better
benefit of that he's just extremely
ignorant in this area and hopefully he
can
retract some of this and he can go ahead
and rethink
his position and actually invite a
muslim scholar on his show
and have a friendly dialogue on these
type of topics so we can go deeper and
deeper but all you have to do is put
slavery in the bible and you'll see what
comes up
and what's his stance on it i mean it's
clear like from paul's teachings
where he says slaves are to obey their
masters and to respect and to fear
and with sincerity of heart just as you
obey christ
so you got to be fair you know to make
such a statement
you know a gross insult attack on
prophet muhammed peace and blessing to
be upon him
should prophet muhammed who was a slave
trader so when we evaluate things
historically in context
when you look at the life of prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
and then also his companions and you
look at things in context
and you see how islam truly came to free
the necks of the slave
we went over that how empowered educated
and and
it just gives you a different
perspective coming to the
the right sources instead of going to
the wrong ones i gave you that example
you don't go to the kkk to learn about
black history
and you don't go to communists to learn
about god so you don't go to anti-muslim
islam haters
people who have a malicious agenda to
learn about islam so i'm going to leave
you some books
to go ahead and read for our friend
patrick ben david
but before i do that i want to share
with you
what some non-muslim academics
thinkers historians had to say i'll
start off with michael h
hart who was the author of
the ranking of the most influential
persons in history so this is a
historian putting
a very well-known book academic piece
together
and what did he have to say he said that
my choice of muhammad
peace and blessing be upon to lead the
list of the world's most influential
persons may surprise some readers and
may be questioned by others
but he was the only man in history who
was
surprisingly who was supremely
successful on both the religious and
secular
level so that was one person he's not a
muslim
and he put muhammad number one i mean so
it just motivates you to to want to
learn more
about his life let's go on to the next
person reverend bosworth smith he says
he was caesar and pope in one but he was
the pope without the pope's pretensions
and caesar without the legions of caesar
without a standing army without a
bodyguard without a palace
without a fixed revenue if ever any man
had the right to say that he
ruled by a right divine he was muhammad
for he had all the power without its
instruments
and without its supports let me give you
a
couple more for our friend patrick and
the like who's out there who become
victims of the hate propaganda hate
machine
so they can learn and grow and be
enlightened
and learn truly learn
from the right sources so you can go
ahead and just expand
all of us don't know everything but if
you go to the wrong sources you're going
to get the wrong information there's a
beautiful quote once said from a thinker
empty the old make room for the new as
you can only make a good decision based
on the info that you know so god willing
this information is going to help you
to make a better judgment call next time
you utter islam or you have
a islam hater on your show or
your have these this baggage that you
carry from some bad experiences back in
iran or
from from wherever you were and some of
the history there
this doesn't represent islam because
islam is perfect human beings are
imperfect
so let's go back to a couple more quotes
from some
non-muslims and what they had to say
about prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him thomas carlisle
who's another academic
another intellectual look at what he had
to say the lies
which well meaning zeal has heaped
around this man
muhammad are disgraceful to ourselves
only you also have a strong woman's
activist
a author of over 300 books an academic
an intellectual a annie bessette
it is impossible for anyone who studies
the life and character of this great
prophet of arabia
who knew how he taught and how he lived
to feel anything but great reverence
for that mighty prophet one of the great
messengers of the supreme
and although in what i put to you i
shall say many things which
may be familiar to many yet i myself
feel whenever i reread them a
new way a new way of admiration
a new sense of reverence for the mighty
arabian teacher why would this woman
what does she have to gain
i mean what if he was an oppressor of
women if he was like you said
he was prophet muhammed who was a slave
traders
why do why are these people who look the
difference between them is someone who's
looking at his life objectively
sincerely and then
people who are again going to the hate
machine
looking for information and then making
the wrong judgment call
mahatma gandhi you know he was very very
well known for his nine
violent protests trying to get
to where he needed to get with
non-violent protests so why would he
say something like this what i'm going
to read at the end why why if muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him was like
these people try to make him out to be
look he said i wanted to know
the best of the life of the one who
holds today an undisputed sway over the
hearts
of millions of mankind i became more
than ever convinced that it was not he
said it was not the sword that wanted
place
for islam in those days in the scheme of
life
it was the rigid simplicity the utter
self-enhancement of the prophet
the scrupulous regard for pledges his
intense
devotion to the friends to his friends
and followers his intrepidity his
fearlessness
his absolute trust in god and his own
mission
these are not these and not he says
not the sword carried everything before
them and surmounted every obstacle when
i close the second
pay attention to this last part this is
very very amazing
he says when i close the second volume
of prophet muhammad's biography
it behooves you patrick ben david to
read
the life of prophet muhammad written by
a muslim
look or even karen armstrong who's not a
muslim this is this is a good biography
go ahead and read
right read this is the first these are
the first look
words from the quran they reveal ikara
look read
this is what the human being to know you
must read look readers are leaders so
now look if you want to be a true leader
you should go help help make bridges not
destroy them
with this type of vile vile nest that
came out from your mouth
should prophet muhammed who was a slave
trader should mosques be torn down
may god almighty guide you we want the
best for you
we want god to guide you and we'll end
it with this one look at this is from
george bernard shaw look patrick look
what he had to say
he must be called the savior of humanity
i believe that if a man like him were to
assume the dictatorship of the modern
world
he would succeed in solving his problems
in a way that would bring it much
needed peace and happiness and i ended
with that
patrick look we're in need of much peace
and happiness in the world as you know
it
there's much strife there's much
division
and the fact of the matter is that
christians are not going anywhere
jews are not going anywhere muslims are
not going anywhere
so we need to work together to make this
planet that we live on a better place
now we can agree to disagree on things
peacefully
and in a benign way but if we're gonna
insult each other if we're going to
utter words of disrespect to each other
that's not gonna help us to
plant seeds of goodness for us and our
families that's only going to fuel more
fire
and mule feel more hate and that hate
leads to violence
so you have to decide on what side you
want to be on
the side that helps truly promote peace
and understanding and that's through the
right education that's why
i put this we put this video together
for you my friend and the likes
like i said i praised some of your work
i even shared some of your work i really
still to this day i think everybody
should watch this debate with
with robert f kennedy jr that you had on
your program and you have another
some other great guests so for us to
really connect to understand each other
we have to make the human connection we
got to sit and talk
ask those questions and come to us
instead of talking about us
instead of talking about islam get to
know islam
and let me just leave you with some
homework one read a good translation of
the quran
the quran is in its original arabic
tamper-free temple proof we have it in
his pristine form
but a good translation you have sahih
international or the clear quran.com
you can go there i mean that's the
beautiful thing i mean you promote
reading
you promote reading and you even have
videos talking about how you can fit
reading into your day through while
exercising
right before you go to bed while running
while taking a bath so
you encourage people to read read this
we're asking you
to read some give you some books to read
my friend this is only gonna
enlighten you and better you and help
you to grow from this
situation now look the quran that's
number one
read it you've talked about reading over
a thousand books
i mean why not add one more it's not
going to hurt you look
the life of prophet muhammed so let me
give you a few recommendations
you have a mercy to the universe
this book is a great book it's
publishers by daryl islam
read this book uh there's a muslim
anonymous amount there karama is strong
she's a non-muslim so if you don't want
to read the book by the muslim but i
really encourage you to do that
read karen armstrong's book biography of
prophet muhammad let me give you a
couple more books the eternal challenge
for somebody who doesn't like to read
maybe i'll give him a pamphlet or
something
but you love to read so i gave you a few
more a few extra
and then try to have a muslim on your
show you debated the communists
come let's have a dialogue invite a
muslim i can help you and
those who are out there who call
themselves the conservative the
conservative christians
muslims in them have a lot in common and
you'd be surprised if we sat together
talked together
we broke bread together you'll see that
we can we can work together
for many great causes right many get
great causes and when they learn our
deep love and reverence from jesus we
say peace be upon him his blessed mother
and they see all these other things they
see that muslims
antichrists far for from being the
antichrist
we have to believe in love jesus christ
is one of the mightiest messengers ever
sent
to mankind that he called people to
worship the one and only created the
heavens and earth and that's the one
that we worship and we say peace be upon
him
prophet muhammad and all the messengers
because they again as i started with
they all came with what would bring
people peace and purpose that was
directing people to worship
not creation nothing on the earth
but the one above the heavens the
creator the heavens and earth
the one and only creator god almighty
and every we just say allah and you
speak arabic so you know allah is the
one god that's it
period and to be morally upright that's
the simple message my friend
and to promote justice and peace so
i hope you got to benefit from this and
you can see that it was out of the love
that we put this together
helping to educate because education is
key to remove
much of this ignorance out there and
you'll be a part of that removing the
ignorance
and you can add this to your resume of
good
that a human being is trying to do
otherwise
where they at if they're spreading hate
and this false propaganda lies where you
at then
in life huh you're just part of the
problem not salute not the solution
and for everybody else out there
continue to tune in here to the dean
show
subscribe if you haven't liked this
video share it far and wide
and support us on our patreon page so we
can continue his work thank you very
much peace be with you assalamu alaikum
i can't stand the veil i can't stand the
veil i can't stand the veil
notice these are christian women in the
church
this video is especially important to
anyone who has
ever looked down upon a muslim woman
wearing hijab
who has ever had this hate towards a
muslim woman because she wears hijab
i can't stand the veil some who have
even stooped to such an
evil low level plotting to bring harm
to a muslim woman in hijab as we've seen
a manifestation of that hate in violence
in recent times
look at these women and then go type in
mary the mother of jesus in google
search
tell me what you see you see her in
hijab
that modest non-revealing her body
apparel
now if you were to ask a christian why
are these women
that you're watching in this video these
christian nuns
why are these christian nuns dressed
this way in modesty
it's the same way a muslim woman in
hijab
the answer would be because they are the
best of our women who have
dedicated their lives to god and
everyone can respect and admire that is
something very noble honorable and
righteous
we can agree right but a muslim woman
who wears hijab
is basically doing the same exact thing
dedicating her life to the love and
pleasure of god almighty
so why the double standards why the
hypocrisy
it's very embarrassing i'm telling you
it's very embarrassing and hypocritical
when you see people hate filled
media personalities politicians
and sadly preachers who make fun
of bully attack innocent muslim women
i can't stand the veil but it's exactly
the same
in their own book hijab is in the bible
look it's right in front of you open
your eyes
most importantly open your heart the
bible says
enlightenment are old and like men also
that women
are doing themselves in modest
appearance what
is so modest about this
open your hearts you're watching the
best
of the christian woman right here in
this video
wearing the same exact thing muslim
woman wear this is the hijab
in front of you
i want you to remember this the next
time you see a muslim woman in hijab
who's following the example of mary
the mother of jesus observing the
highest level of
modesty and morality dedicating her life
to the almighty
to the creator allah you have to have
nothing but tremendous respect to all
the women who wear the hijab
practicing modesty this modest lifestyle
inwardly and outwardly
with modest clothing that resembles mary
the mother of jesus
and not imitating the kardashians
beyonce
perry mary miley cyrus
and the rest of them with let it all out
freak show
especially with all of the ignorant
people out there
the hot weather the societal pressures
the sexualization of women making them
feel not worthy
enough or making them feel ugly if they
don't copy the others who are walking
half dressed or
hack half naked out there selling
themselves and their souls
turning themselves into slaves of
fashion desires and a corrupt industry
making them fake much respect to the
women of hijab
who respect themselves and most of all
who
love their creator
more than any of these superficial fake
things
may god almighty may the creator allah
reward
all of you with jannah
and grant you the best in this life and
the best in the hereafter
and guide all of those who are sincerely
seeking
the creator's guidance thank you peace
this is modest
what's wrong with this what's wrong with
it
how in the world you expect for a man to
come and
trust and think about jesus and you
looking like a stripper
talk to me
bible says let the women that women
adorn themselves how
in modest apparel modest modest
respectable presentable